chris dodson owner of ecoelectric today
with a helpful hint for homeowners about
smoke detectors manufacturers recommend
that smoke detectors be changed about
every 10 years
and a good indicator of an older smoke
detector
is when the exterior cover starts to
yellow in between replacements
you do have to change batteries so once
a year you're going to change the
battery and i'll show you how
the battery cover is usually located on
the outside but
sometimes it may be on the back side you
twist and remove and you'll find it on
the back side
wherever that battery compartment is you
open the battery compartment
install the new battery close it and you
want to hit
test on each smoke detector as you go
and that will
reset the smoke detector and ensure that
they're all communicating with one
another and working properly
if you do have smoke detector issues and
you need an electrician to come out
there and check them out
possibly replace them ecoelectric does
provide that service
give us a call at ecoelectric or visit
our website